>> All right. So, I'm going to highlight this
logical test. And delete it. Is that okay?
>> Yup. And, insert the field.
>> Okay. So in this case, I'm checking if ticket type, which is way down
here, is equal to VIP.
>> In quotes.
>> In quotes. And the quotes are for?
>> because it's a string.
>> String. So just some text.
So if the ticket type is VIP, and the total spent
is 100 times the number of tickets sold, which is a field.
>> Exactly. And then the value, false, let's say, you know, is $50 for, so
it'd be the exact same thing, but it would be 50 times the tickets purchased.
>> Okay.
>> And you don't have to go through inserting the field that
way, you can just type it out, or copy and paste it.
>> Can I like, hit enter
here, and make it a little neater? I don't know,
it's hard for me to keep this all in line.
>> Sure.
>> Okay, so this should work, let's
check syntax. Uh-oh. Field type, field ticket
type C is a picklist field. Picklist
fields are only supported in certain functions.